hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 american science fiction and drama
movie called everything everywhere all
at once
the movie begins with a chinese-american
middle-aged woman evelyn wang who is
going through a busy morning
she checks receipts from her laundromat
business because its tax report is being
audited by the irs and she has an
appointment with the auditor this
afternoon
her husband weymond wants to talk about
divorce but she seems too busy to pay
attention to him so he ends up doing
house chores instead
their daughter joy comes to the house
with her girlfriend becky evelyn plans
to bring her father gong gong to the
auditor appointment this afternoon while
joy and becky can stay at home and
decorate for gong gong's party later
tonight before evelyn can sit down
customers come to the laundromat so she
heads there to serve them overwhelmed
with tasks she asks wayman to help while
joy tries to talk to her to bring becky
to gong gong's party tonight and
introduce her to him but evelyn tells
her to let gong gong enjoy his party
while weyman prepares gong gong's
breakfast evelyn introduces becky to him
as joy's good friend instead of
girlfriend
joy is devastated by that choice of
words and storms off the laundromat
evelyn waymond and gong gong attend the
auditor appointment at the irs office
as the elevator goes up wayman suddenly
acts strange by blocking the cctv and
telling evelyn that she is in grave
danger he gives evelyn an earpiece and
activates it making evelyn relive her
life from childhood until now he gives
her a choice to head for the janitor's
room or to still attend the appointment
with deirdre their auditor
confused she asks him why she would go
to the janitor's room but he refuses to
explain
he writes down some absurd instructions
on paper instead and tells her to follow
those while she is attending her
appointment the auditor seems to be
unhappy with the audit and asks many
questions but wayman manages to find
answers while evelyn keeps thinking
about a strange behavior
she checks the instruction which tells
her to switch her shoes to the wrong
feet and imagine herself being in the
janitor's closet the action splits her
consciousness one in the auditor's
appointment and another in the janitor's
closet where she meets another version
of waymon from a different universe
however weymouth only tells her that she
will know when it is the time to fight
then he is being chased by another evil
version of deirdre causing evelyn to
panic and confusing everyone in her main
universe wayman suspects that evelyn
panics because she has read the
statement of divorce he is going to
issue so he explains it to her which
just makes evelyn even more confused
she then sees deirdre coming at them
perceives it to be a threat wayman told
her earlier and punches deirdre
everyone at the office is shocked and
reports the incident to the police
the other wayman appears again this time
using his martial art skills to save
themselves
meanwhile in another universe where
evelyn and wayman did not survive the
attack at the janitor's closet evelyn is
killed off by a mysterious cult leader
whom the evil deirdre worships jobu
tupaki
jobu is disappointed knowing that evelyn
is not the one she is looking for and
switches her consciousness to other
versions of herself throughout the
multiverse ending up possessing joys
back in the irs office the wayman from
another universe explains to evelyn that
every slight variation in reality
creates a branching universe
he comes from the first universe to make
contact with others the alpha verse
in that universe evelyn now deceased was
a brilliant woman who discovered a way
to temporarily link a person's
consciousness to other versions of
themselves accessing their memories
emotions and skills a method called
verse jumping
she was killed by jobu tupaki an
ambitious being with no real motives who
is building a sort of black hole
he thinks this universe is evelyn can
stop jobu thus risking everything to
save her
they encounter the evil deirdre again
who performs verse jumping to gain the
abilities of a pro wrestler and attacks
them alpha weyman tries to verse jump
but deirdre knocks his device and traps
him in a room leaving evelyn defenseless
through a phone call alpha weyman tells
evelyn she must verse jump imagining
herself in a universe where she knows
martial arts
after that she must perform a weird task
to deliver her consciousness to that
universe this time telling deirdre that
she loves her
she attempts to do it but is sent to
another universe where she finished
deirdre's appointment and is having a
conversation about divorce with weymouth
in the car
after another attempt while still being
chased by evil deirdre she finally finds
herself in a universe where she did not
stay with weymouth almost got robbed and
met a kung fu master who took her as an
apprentice as a result she mastered kung
fu and is now famously known as an
action movie actress
using her kung fu skills she defeats
deirdre and retreats with waymon to a
meeting room
there she keeps seeing flashes of her
life as a famous actress so alpha wayman
tells her that verse jumping causes
cracks in her mind
she needs to reseal those cracks to not
confuse herself with other versions of
her he also explains that jobu tupaki is
their daughter from another universe
whose mind is fractured due to
overloading herself with verse jumps
instead of dying like most people who
cannot withstand the overwhelming verse
jump effect her mind now experiences all
of the universes and possibilities at
the same time and she is hunting every
evelyn evelyn drifts back to the kung fu
universe where she meets waymon who is a
wealthy businessman
back in her universe she and weymon are
detained by the police but jobu tupaki
possessing joy appears and defeats the
police using her reality manipulation
skills evelyn tries to use her kung fu
skills against jobu but she drifts to a
universe where every human has floppy
hot dogs on their hands instead of
fingers and evelyn is in a relationship
with deirdre jobu presents evelyn with a
black hole she has been building which
is shaped like a bagel
it consumes everything that represents
jobu's belief that nothing matters
because the multiverses are always in
never-ending chaos
she is then hit by gong gong whose
consciousness is temporarily hijacked by
his alpha-verse counterpart weymon
realizes that this evelyn is so bad at
everything that if she verse jumps she
can acquire any skills mastered by a
more successful version of herself in
other universes
the multiversal travelers then seem to
disappear leaving this universe's
weymouth and joy extremely confused
about what is going on
to prevent jobu from hurting her evelyn
duct tapes her to a chair
she then tries to explain the verse
jumping to them that their physical
bodies are controlled like puppets like
in the ratatouille movie but she
mistakenly says rakakuni
alpha gong gong wants to kill this
universe's joy giving jobu one less
universe to access
evelyn refuses attacking him instead so
she can escape with her family
furious alpha gong gong instructs other
people in the alpha verse to verse jump
to that universe and hunt evelyn down
evelyn realizes her ability to withstand
many verse jumps can make her become
just like jobu tupaki but it will make
her strong enough to defeat jobu so she
continues verse jumping to access useful
skills to battle the alpha verse minions
such as acquiring improved lung capacity
from singer evelyn deflecting weapons
from pizza guy evelyn and mastering hand
to hand combats and weapons from chef
evelyn meanwhile in the alpha verse
alpha weymouth is killed after jobu
tupaki finds him
evelyn is deeply saddened after alpha
weyman's consciousness truly disappears
leaving her with her universe as weymond
she then drifts off to the kung fu
universe where she is sitting through
the premiere of her film
jumping to other universes she realizes
that in the chef universe her co-worker
chad truly has a raccoon beneath his
chef hat the raka cooney just like
ratatouille she jumps verse again this
time arriving in a universe where there
was no fight in the irs office and gone
gong's party is about to get started
weymouth instructs her to drop the
paperwork and cookies off to deirdre
she goes out to meet joy but realizes
jobu has taken over her again
they fight but manage to act normal when
waymon appears
wayman reminds her to take care of the
irs paperwork then leaves
jobu takes evelyn to the bagel and
seemingly wants to throw her into it
evelyn begs jobu to leave her alone with
joy but she refuses as she and joy are
the same person
moreover she wants to destroy herself by
jumping into the bagel and is seeking a
version of evelyn who can understand her
to join her as well
as their minds were fractured they
experience every version of themselves
simultaneously never being fully present
in a particular moment evelyn is tempted
to join jobu doing devastating things in
parallel universes such as stabbing
weiman and revealing the raccoon beneath
chad's chef hat
back at gong gong's party as evelyn
never deliver the paperwork to irs
deirdre comes to the laundromat and
authorizes police to seize the business
wayman begs her to give them another
chance next week to resolve the matter
then somehow deirdre is convinced and
releases evelyn
meanwhile evelyn reminisces the good
memories she had been through with
weymouth with a version of waymon
telling her that she needs to be kind
she snaps back to reality and begins to
have hope again refusing jobu to go into
the bagel and trying to prevent her
daughter from doing so
however jobu's minions try to stop her
evelyn manipulates reality to overcome
their attacks such as transforming
bullets into harmless google eyes
remembering wayman's message to be kind
she accesses the memories of jobu's
minions and gives them something that
brings them happiness such as their
favorite scent of perfume or giving a
back massage
in the chef universe she reconciles with
chad by helping him to get back his
raccoon
in the party universe she finally
introduces becky to gong gong as joy's
girlfriend
however joy is still disappointed in her
mother and then leaves
evelyn chases her to the parking lot
telling her that even though they may
disagree in many situations they still
look for each other in the end
she also prefers to be with joy despite
everywhere else she could be
in another universe evelyn tightly holds
on to jobu who almost enters the bagel
finally helped by gong gong waymund and
others
they both then embrace each other and
reconcile
sometime later things seem to have
improved for evelyn and her family
becky drives them to the irs office for
their auditor appointment
evelyn and weymon share a brief kiss
before they enter the elevator deirdre
now seems happy with their tax reports
but evelyn's mind drifts off to other
universes
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching